Okay.
Oh No, a shorter guy.
Yeah. Well the thing is, I'm just
trying to make an excuse. Right?
Okay
man, I am parched. I need some water.
Fuck
man. I am parched. I need
some water. Yeah. Hey,
task rabbit. Yeah. Could you come
over? I need some help. Yeah, come in.
Yeah, please. Hey, I was,
I just, I really needed the
water bottle over there.
I was wondering if you could get
that for me. Awesome. Thanks so much.
Do you know where we are?
Starving?
We been up here two minutes or something.
I'm done.
Do you know where we are?
Right.
Okay.
Do you think I'll ever get married?
Siri,
do you think I'll ever get married
and then she ate all my pizza.
What am I going to eat?
I'm like homeless now or
something. You know, like,
could you guys like stop being so
absorbed in your books for a second?
Like real life is happening right now.
I'm sorry,
I'm just really into this major
account sales strategy, but
catch you guys and then she like
moved my family down to Florida.
I'm sorry. I just got invited to
a party. We have Facebook, uh,
were all the people who win $1 million.
You got to go.
Yeah, totally. Oh, hey, just
got a text from my girlfriend.
She said she still loves you.
I just got a notification that everything
in your life, it's going to go for it.
Oh my God.
You did.
You guys hear about Sherry's pregnancy?
She totally got pregnant. Yeah. I think
it was with Steve or some shit like that.
Yeah, but, but you guys remember that one
song. It was like, I'm going to kill you.
I'm going to kill you. I'm gonna
kill you. I'm gonna kill you.
Like rock and metal. Yeah.
Right. For Jazz and blues.
I guess we'll never know. Is
it your interpretive? Uh, yeah,
it's, it's uh, Hello James
Vaughn's. Yeah. What's up, bro?
Yeah, yeah. Hold up pink,
you know, 4 million,
368,782 times 48.
Okay. Yo James, it's 53. Okay.
Oh, he was trying to defuse the bomb in
Africa. I would blow up the torque on it.